good afternoon everyone I'm Adrienne Dix
BC's minister of Health joining me today
are Dr Bonnie Henry BC's provincial
Health officer and Dr Penny balum
executive lead of BC's covid-19
immunization plan we're honored to be
here on the territories of the musqueam
of the Squamish of the slave tooth First
Nations
earlier this summer we shared news that
we had started the work necessary to
offer a fall booster dose many of us
might recall receiving texts on this
important safety step in mid-july when
summer was just getting underway or at
least it seemed that way
and with today marking back to school
the end of summer holidays the time of
year when we get back to it we're here
to announce the details of the Fall
booster campaign it's a welcome step
that builds upon previous efforts and
advances especially Health Canada's news
during the summer that it had approved a
pediatric covid-19 vaccine a booster
dose for children ages 5 to 11. and on
September 1st approval of a new booster
dosed a bivalent one that Dr Henry will
talk about in a few moments for all of
us with covet all around us it's been a
busy summer British Columbians have
continued to protect ourselves our loved
ones and our communities by getting
vaccinated in record numbers as of
August 15th 92 percent of people in BC
age 12 and old older had received the
two dose primary series and more than 12
million coveted 19 vaccines had been
administered we started offering the
Pediatric vaccine on August 2nd and and
two weeks later 20 000 children had
registered to get their shot and I again
Ask parents to register their children
today
getting our vaccines and our boosters
for ourselves and our children have
protected us against severe covet
outcomes requiring hospitalization which
has eased coveted stress on our health
care System a stress that continues
nonetheless to exist fifteen thousand
eight hundred healthcare workers in the
last week where we provided we have
information which is the week to prior
to the weekend and Labor Day we're off
sick that week significantly above the
usual numbers and that has an impact
everywhere in our health care System
but simply when we get our vaccines and
our boosters we save lives it's vital
work getting our vaccines and keeping up
with our boosters and our ongoing
ongoing commitment to this effort has
made and will continue to make all the
difference to each of us and how we Face
covet and how we live with coven
on that point we're here today to
provide an update on our fall booster
campaign and I I now invite Dr Bonnie
Henry to talk about The Fall season and
how we can continue to protect ourselves
Dr Henry
thank you very much and good afternoon
I want to start by talking a little bit
about where we are in this pandemic and
what we all need to think about as we
start back to school and work for many
people and head into the respiratory
illness season this fall and winter
very uncertain trajectory of the
pandemic in the next few months and
while I do believe we are emerging from
the Pandemic part of it it is clear that
covid-19 will be with us for the long
term
it is still in my opinion though an
unusual event one for which we need to
continue to take coordinated measures
together we know that we for example
still have our special advisory
committee nationally the who has still
called this a public health incident of
international concern
and we know that there is still
significant spread around the world and
the public health impact of the
emergence of potentially another variant
of concern is still one of the
uncertainties that we have to live with
right now
but we do know more and more about the
virus and about how we can manage both
individually and collectively in this
province
but we are not yet at a point where we
can let our guard down both here and
globally and the public health emergency
that we have here and the measures that
enable the measures to that we can take
remain important
we also need to continue to pay
attention to the things we know will
help against covid-19 and also in the
context of what we may be facing in the
coming respiratory season things like
influenza RSV and other serious
respiratory illnesses
so while my team have been working a lot
about through this summer to try and
give a sense of what we might be facing
in the fall and winter and we'll be
talking more about that next week
we do know that the covet climate the
climate that we're in gives us a sense
of where we are in the pandemic and it's
measuring things that we provide
information on like rates of illnesses
we know that that is focused on the
people who are most likely to need
treatment or to have interventions as a
result of their illness the PCR testing
but also on hospitalizations ICU cases
people who end up dying from covid-19
and we also look very closely at
outbreaks and long-term care homes in
assisted living in schools now that kids
are back and other surveillance markers
like Wastewater testing serial
prevalence studies that we are doing on
an ongoing basis and those all give us a
sense a picture of of what's happening
in our community over time those are not
things that change on a day-to-day basis
but they do change over weeks and months
and that's why we provide the weekly
information that we have been providing
and we've been working on and we'll give
as I mentioned some details next week
but we also need to look at you know
what is the weather on a day-to-day
basis like we would look outside and say
yeah it's summer so are we expecting sun
or rain do I need sunscreen or do I need
my umbrella and when we look at that
from a covet perspective it means
looking about how am I feeling today if
I have a cough or a fever then maybe I
need to stay away from others what am I
going to be doing today am I going to be
in a crowded place with lots of people
maybe I need to take a mask with me
what's happening in my community that
covert climate but also looking at
um these the things that I can do to see
if I'm okay today and that is staying up
to date on my vaccinations making sure
that I'm cleaning my hands regularly
covering my mouth when I'm coughing
staying home if we're not feeling well
and the things that we need to think
about now are not the same as the ones
that we thought about over the last
couple of years where we didn't have the
level of immunity that we have now but
things that are indicators that we may
be infectious to others are things like
having a fever and a cough fever and a
rash those are things that are from our
past that we may remember having nausea
vomiting diarrhea those are things that
can be infectious to others and we're
likely to see more of those as we go
into this fall season
so I need to think about what am I doing
what setting is it going to be and if
there's lots of covet or even influenza
circulating maybe I need to stay away
from high risk settings if I'm at risk
myself or if I'm not feeling well
postpone that visit to somebody who's
going through Cancer Treatments or to
visiting your grandmother in long-term
care until you're feeling better those
are all the things that we need to think
about on a daily basis as we're going
into this fall and winter and of course
cleaning our hands regularly and staying
up to date on vaccination
it is without a doubt vaccination that
has allowed us to get to this point
where we no longer need to have broad
imposed measures like Mass mandates like
closures like distancing that we know
are so disruptive to society and that we
need it to slow the spread of SARS cov2
when everybody was susceptible and we
knew that severe illness could happen to
large numbers of people
but because so many people have stepped
up and received their immunizations we
are in a very different climate now than
we are we're even just a year ago the
level of immunity that we have from
infection and vaccination has been a
game changer and we know the virus has
changed as well and that has changed
what we've had to do
but we need to keep it up to be certain
we are protecting those most at risk and
protecting our Health Care system in the
coming months
I'd also like to talk a little bit about
immunity against covet 19.
so immunity can mean a lot of things and
many people think of it as an all or
nothing but our body's immune systems
are complex and we've talked about this
quite a few times immunity is our body's
ability to protect us from getting sick
getting infected in the first place but
also getting sick or seriously ill from
a pathogen an agent such as a virus such
as sarsko V2
and we have learned over this last two
and a half years a great deal about
covid-19 the the illness about sarsko V2
the virus and about immunity
since we've had vaccines as well we know
our immune system is complex and
responds both to vaccine and to
infection and that immunity is not just
on off it can be different in different
ways and it's not just one size fits all
we know that an infection-induced
immunity what some people call natural
immunity is the immune protection we get
when we're infected with the virus
whether it's the original strain the
Delta the Omicron it gives a different
level of immune response and I've talked
a number of times but we have two main
parts to our immune system and one of
those is the antibodies that are
generated when we're infected with a
virus and those antibodies are in our
blood and over time those go down
but the second part of our immune system
is our cell mediated immune system and
those are those memory cells they have
great names like killer cells that that
remain in our our body and when we get
exposed to that same virus again they
can come up and protect us from getting
really seriously ill with the virus
we also know that as many as one in
eight people and this is from data that
was done here in Canada and also in
other parts of the world who are
infected and don't infect it but not
vaccinated so people who have only
infection whether it's from original
Wuhan strain from Delta from Omicron
about one in eight people don't develop
a protective immune response so they may
have antibodies for a short period of
time but those May fade away and they
may not have stimulated that stronger
longer lasting response from the
cell-mediated immunity and we know that
this immunity decreases over time and is
different with different variants and we
see that particularly with Omicron that
if you have a mild infection with
Omicron and you don't have your system
primed through vaccination that you may
not develop serial conversion or enough
of that strength immunity so that you
can more likely to be reinfected you're
more likely to have more severe illness
we also know that vaccine-induced
immunity is also complex and when we
know now that it gives strong protection
against any infection after two doses
but it's better after three so really
three doses is important for longer
lasting stronger protection both from
those antibodies which also fade over
time but that stronger cell-mediated
immunity that we now know from the
vaccine Effectiveness studies done here
in BC done in Canada and elsewhere that
it gives you longer lasting protection
against severe illness and that is
preserved for many many months and years
for some people we also know we've
learned that if you're older if you have
certain immune compromising conditions
you may need more vaccine and you may
your immune system tends to to decrease
that protection sooner than people who
have a good strong immune system
so we need to protect those people with
additional doses when we see surges in
Transmission in the community
we also have a new thing that we've come
to understand a lot more and that we
we've now learned that there's better
and sometimes longer lasting protection
with hybrid immunity so when somebody is
both vaccinated and has had an infection
this is especially true now with the
Omicron where we've seen lots of
infections and I think everybody knows
at least somebody who's been infected
this summer
but those infections have been mostly
mild because we've primed our immune
system it stimulates those antibodies it
stimulates those cell-mediated immunity
so even people who might have had a
severe infection before their immune
system is able to recognize the virus
and protect them in a way that we
haven't had before
so what does all this mean
with vaccination and with hybrid
immunity we now know that there are far
fewer people in our community now today
who are at risk of severe illness from
covet and we have tools now to top up
immunity for those people who are still
at risk and that includes the newest
approved bivalent vaccine booster in
addition we have treatments that can be
used for people who are most at risk if
they do get infected including things
like paxilavid and citroving them
so the new bivalent vaccine is a
combination vaccine and we use
multivalent vaccines you know bias just
means two so this one has two different
proteins in it these types of
combination vaccines are actually very
common the most common one that people
probably know very well they're
influenza vaccines and influenza
vaccines have three or four different
strains of influenza in this in the one
product we also have polio vaccines and
pneumococcal vaccines that have
multivalence in them as well so every
year we know that scientists combine
activity against a number of the recent
strains of influenza for example and
that is included in the latest vaccine
so this is very similar to what we're
doing now with covid
as you know last week Health Canada
approved the use of a combination
bivalent covid-19 vaccines it's approved
for use in adults 18 years of age and
older and I'll talk a little bit about
that in a minute so this is a form of
combination vaccine that has the spike
protein in it not just for the original
Wuhan variant but also for an Omicron
variant and it is based on the Omicron
ba1
but clinical Studies have shown that it
that ba1 component of the bivalent
vaccine stimulates a very strong immune
boost against all of the Oma constrains
including ba45 so that's important I
know the U.S has approved a bivalent
vaccine that includes the ba-45
more closely related one but in Canada
the one that's been approved with all
the data that we have is the one that's
bivalent with ba1 and that in the
clinical studies has shown to give a
really strong increased boost against
all of the Omicron subvariants so I
think that's important for us to to
recognize
and so this version as I said was
designed against the ba1 and we know
that it is ba45 that we're seeing most
commonly now particularly the A5 but
it's not a dramatically different strain
it's not a new variant it's not a new
variant of concern it's still within
that Omicron and so we're seeing good
protection
it also protects against infection so
that's the part with the antibodies in
your blood that we see decreases in all
of us the most and there's lots of good
reasons for that we know that the
protection lasts best in the first eight
to 12 weeks after you get your booster
shot that's important because as we're
putting all of these pieces together for
thinking what might happen in the coming
weeks and months we want the people who
are most at risk to have that boost up
that Top-Up of their protection so that
they have antibodies to protect them
from infection when we expect to see
covet increasing again and as I said
we'll be talking some more about that
but what we're looking at is probably
November December
and the other things that we're putting
into the mix is it's very likely we're
going to see influenza this year we
haven't seen influenza in the last
couple of years but people are traveling
more we're doing more together so it's
and we look at what happened in
Australia New Zealand we see that
influenza was a fairly Bad season this
past year for them and it came early
so what we're planning for and what we
need to think about is how do we best
protect people from influenza from covid
at a time where they both might be
circulating and that is really November
December so that's a little of the
thinking that's been going into who's
going to get this by the valent vaccine
booster and when
so that the timing will be based on risk
and on the time since your last dose
so first of all we need to know who are
the people most at risk for poor
outcomes from covid-19 and I think this
will be no surprise to anybody we have
learned that there are people whose
immune systems don't respond as well and
decrease faster and primarily that is
people who are immune compromised doing
to underlying disease or due to the
medications they're on and people of
older age
so it includes people being treated for
cancer people with chronic kidney liver
lung diseases pregnant people and those
and a number of other disorders and
medications and people over the age of
60 particularly over the age of 80 but
we really want to protect people over
the age of 60. and Nasi recommends of
our national advisory committee on
immunization has put out their statement
on who should get a fall booster and
it's based on people who've had their
vaccine for six months or more had their
last dose was six months or more and
though there's some leeway there
depending on circumstances but at least
three months since the last dose and for
some people and Dr Balan will get into
some of those details we may want to
give it prior to six months like if we
have a local outbreak or so that we can
do residents of a long-term care
facility for example all at the same
time
um the other group that we now need to
look at is people who have hybrid
immunity that I talked about and we
people should wait at least three months
after having an infection before you get
your next booster dose that allows your
immune system to mature and to develop
that boost from the infection as well
I think it is also very important to say
to people who are not vaccinated even if
you've had an infection we know you are
at higher risk of being reinfected and
higher risk of having more severe
illness if you're reinfected so you
should be vaccinated on top of having
had an infection whether it was Delta
whether it was in 2020 or whether it was
recent from Omicron immunization will
help develop a stronger longer lasting
immunity and you are eligible for your
dose one today and I encourage anybody
who's not been immunized to go out and
get that vaccine now
in terms of the bivalent combination
vaccine the following people will be
offered around six months so people
residents of long-term care facilities
Assisted Living Homebound and other
congregate living settings for seniors
older age adults age 60 and up people
who are what we've described as
clinically extremely vulnerable and we
have three groups of those in BC and
particularly those age 12 and up with an
underlying medical condition or
disability adults people who are First
Nations metis or Inuit or from those
communities where infection can have
disproportionate consequences
residents of other concrete living
settings like migrant workers shelters
correctional facilities
and uh
and everybody else
should consider getting this fall
booster and I would say you should think
about getting this at the same time as
you get your flu shot because that will
give you the best protection as we head
in to the highest risk period
I will say that some of the long-term
care facilities if you remember many of
the people who are recommended strongly
to get this by valent dose or people who
were eligible for a dose four a second
booster and that was and when we get to
october-ish that'll be about five five
and a half months since we started that
fourth dose program so they'll be rolled
into getting that vaccine then and that
we think will give the best possible
protection for all of us as we're
expecting to see a surge of covet in the
November December time frame
so as we were beginning this fall
respiratory illness season we need to do
so with the best protection we can if
you've just had your booster it's okay
to wait three to six months to get
another one and I've also encouraged all
of those who've received their
invitation for a booster who are young
and healthy and haven't got that third
dose to get it now it will give you that
stronger longer lasting protection
through the fall and I also want to
thank everybody we are here where we are
in BC because everybody has stepped up
so many people have done what we've done
to protect ourselves our family and our
communities and it's made a tremendous
difference
and I'll now turn over to Dr ballum Who
provide more information on when and
where the vaccine will be available
thanks so much Dr Henry and Minister Dix
and good afternoon to everyone it's
always a privilege to
be here to be part of this really
remarkable effort to bring our lives
back to normal
in the midst of a pandemic
what I'd like to do is just walk you
through some of the specifics of how
this fall booster program will
will proceed and I'll just catch up on a
few things just on our activity over the
last six months
over this time the vaccine program
really since the peak of the first
booster program you'll remember that
started in November and carried through
to throughout January and since that
time we've continued to offer vaccines
for people who come to us with whatever
dose no doses dose one dose two a
booster we've had a lot going on and
we've continued to deliver the program
through pharmacies and through the
health authorities
on average about 85 percent of the
vaccinations that we've done over the
last
six months have been done in our
Pharmacy sector and I just really want
to do a shout out to them they've really
done a remarkable job in coordination
with the BC Pharmacy Association
and the health authorities have done the
rest of the job and and they have a
harder job to do their their job is to
do the Outreach for people who are hard
to find people are frail elderly and
Facilities homebound people frail people
who are not able to come out to a clinic
so they they have a hard job to do in
terms of the numbers
um not not such a high volume as the 600
or so pharmacies who have continued to
provide vaccine
and the health authorities have also
done the children's campaigns both the 5
to 11 campaign and then the the most
recent six months to four year
vaccination program that was authorized
in mid-august by
um by Nasi
so since March 2022 we've delivered the
spring booster campaign for our most
vulnerable individuals those over 70 and
those who are medically very susceptible
to infection due to immune suppression
and
Indigenous peoples
um the moderna vaccine was introduced as
I said for six months to four years the
modern Pediatric and we just as Minister
Dix mentioned we just commenced the
first booster for children 5 to 11.
so today all individuals six months of
age and over are eligible for
vaccination against covet
and we
from five on up as you'll see are all
eligible for a booster this fall and we
really want to just put in uh you know
this is the first day of school
children across the province are
returning to school and it's very very
important that as parents and families
grandparents that we really try and
ensure that those children and youth are
protected against covid they're going
into a setting where you know we know
they want to participate in many
activities and not be home ill and so
getting vaccinated whether they're
unvaccinated or they've they're actually
eligible now for their first booster or
they've been eligible for a while if
they're youth I really want to encourage
that they take advantage of this
campaign where a vaccine will be very
very available across pharmacies and
health authorities
I think in the 5 to 11 age group we we
are hopeful that we will pick up on our
results we have about 58 just under 60
of our 5 to 11 group that have received
dose one and just under 50 Hoovers who
are fully vaccinated with two doses and
just want to you know just encourage
them to carry on and take their vaccine
as it's being made available throughout
the next coming months
the important of being vaccinated does
continue to resonate with our public who
have been so enthusiastic and I just
wanted to share a little factoid with
you that every day in the province 50 to
120 youth or adults actually have
stepped up to get their first dose so
making this available easy to find you
never know what the reason is somebody
who's among the ten nine or ten percent
that are unvaccinated why they'll
suddenly choose to get it but it's
really important that we we remain very
available and encouraging and supportive
to make sure they take that opportunity
and we want to encourage the 1.3 million
people who got fully vaccinated but have
yet to have a booster this is the time
to come in and get your first booster
it's really important as Dr Henry has
explained you are not going to get that
same strength of protection even if
you've had a covet infection and we just
really want to encourage that group
especially to come and get it and I'll
talk to you about you know where the
different groups will be prioritized for
invitations for the fall campaign
so now on to some details Dr Henry's
talked about the new bivalent or
combination vaccine that's modernist
product that has been approved we were
actually hoping we could say today it's
arrived in British Columbia the first
trash but it's not quite there but we're
we're expecting that it's imminent that
we will be getting our first Josh of
that Supply into the province and
basically we anticipate that we'll have
about 1100 pharmacies participating in
this fall booster campaign all around
the province and that there will be on
any daily basis more than 100 health
authority clinics working with the
pharmacies together to provide the
capacity that we need to get our
population
everybody five and up is eligible for a
booster to get them on an expedited
basis able to access this booster and
hopefully as many as possible before we
start getting into respiratory season in
November and December of this year
Health authorities not only will they
have mass clinics but they will also do
as I said all the difficult Outreach to
populations who are you know more
vulnerable are homeless are sheltered
Corrections and as well they do the
facility program so they will be
visiting long-term care ideally we'd
like to wait to do long-term care for
the high-dose flu vaccine that's
specific for that very frail group of
elderly we hope to have that starting
somewhere between the middle and the end
of September and at that point the
health authorities will move out to
start their vaccinations in long-term
care and assisted living
um Dr Henry's alluded to the fact that
we will be co-administering influenza
vaccine for the general population
accessing the fall booster as soon as
it's available and normally That vaccine
arrives in the beginning of in the
beginning of October so we've basically
modeled and planned that starting
probably the week of the third that we
will be able to offer both covid and
influenza when you go to get your
vaccination whether it's a pharmacy that
you're going to or a health authority
Clinic
now just to remind you that the this new
combination by bivalent vaccine will
obviously provide very good protection
not everyone is eligible to receive it
adults 18 years and over have been
approved by Health Canada and
recommended by Nasi to receive the the
new bivalent vaccine
for youth 12 to 17 Dr Henry has
recommended that those who are high risk
have immunosuppression have chronic
medical conditions that compromise them
that they are will be eligible to
receive this bivalent vaccine but for
the rest of Youth we will offer them a
fall booster using the regular vaccine
that has been used to immunize them uh
you know to date with their dose 1 and
dose 2.
we we understand that there is Pfizer
vaccine that is working its way through
the regulatory process and we have had
some information from the the knock
which provides us all the logistical
information about delivery of vaccines
and we're hoping that we will receive
some Pfizer vaccine in the coming weeks
as well that will be a bivalent product
as well but that's still preliminary and
working its way through the regulatory
um uh you know program
so I think one of the things that
everyone wants to know is when am I
going to get my invitation for my fall
booster and you know first of all we
will use our get vaccinated BC system
that I think most of you are familiar
with it's been a terrific system and
some of you have most of you have
accessed it online some have used the
call center to get some help with that
and that will continue to be the case
but we will be sending out our
invitations through that system either
to your email or to a mobile
number and I just want to be clear that
we recently have had an upgrade to the
system that now allows you to actually
go in and update your contact
information which is really important
um not everyone's like me that has had
the same mobile number for 20 years I
gather people do change their number and
so it'll be really important you go on
the get vaccinated system there's an
icon you can click on and then update
whether it's your email or your mobile
so that you'll be sure and get your
invitation
we will flow invitations for the fall
booster campaign based on a number of
variables which are which are mostly
direction from public health and dictate
the priorities
so I'll just go through the key groups
first of all the interval from your last
vaccine is a really important indicator
as Dr Henry has said immunity does Wane
so for those who only got up to dose two
they are well over a year many of them
since they've had their last vaccination
they may have had covid in the meantime
but we we will be targeting especially
those very high priority
individuals in those groups as early
invites to the campaign
those who are clinically extremely
vulnerable so we have three groups of
those those who are immunosuppressed
either severely or moderately and then
people have chronic conditions like
diabetes some of the neurodevelopmental
issues chronic lung disease a whole
variety of conditions that Dr Henry
referred to that's that's the second
high priority group that will be invited
as a priority for the campaign
indigenous our pop our public our
indigenous Community 18 and over
and then we will use the the age cutoff
of 60 years of age to finalize the
priority groups who are vulnerable to
covet infection and to having more
adverse outcomes
healthcare workers is the final group
that I just want to speak to our health
care workers were a high priority when
the first booster came in order to
protect our Health Care system and many
of them are well over six months since
their last dose and we want them to be
protected as Minister dick says to
protect them from getting sick but also
equally important from them you know we
need to protect our patients in our
Institutions and our programs so
healthcare workers are a really
important group and finally the the
group a very vulnerable folks 70 and
over and immunosuppressed who were
invited for the spring booster campaign
as Dr Henry has said we are going to
time their invites so they'll be the
first on deck in October to get the
combined influenza and covid vaccine
opportunity
so
um just a point of uh that Dr Henry's
just referred to elderly and long-term
care Assisted Living homebound
individuals congregate studies who are
considered high risk other high-risk
groups that are we know have adverse
outcomes those in shelters congregate
settings
Corrections facilities the health
authorities are responsible for those
and when the bivalent vaccine arrives
they will be making plans to along with
the long-term care and assisted living
sector they'll be making their plans of
how they'll Outreach in parallel to the
mass clinics and the pharmacy program
that we'll be running across the program
the province
we've built a model for immunized BC to
actually project both who will invite
and what we expect the uptake will be we
will be able to vaccinate at Peak about
250 000 to 280 000 individuals a week so
that's about you know a quarter of a
million or more individuals will get
their vaccine in in any one week and
that capacity will remain for about 10
weeks starting in the middle of
September on September 19th when the
health authorities start up their Mass
clinics and the and the pharmacies the
full Toronto pharmacies who will be
participating about 1100 and we'll run
that capacity as long as we need to as
the demand is Flowing that's about the
maximum that we can we can actually
mobilize for this campaign at that rate
and then as the demand falls off as we
expect it to at the end of November we
will be basically backing off the health
authority clinics and turning the
program over to the pharmacies and then
the Health authorities will carry on
doing the difficult to reach the
facility program and the children
at this time as I said the arrival of
the vaccine the bivalent vaccine is
imminent this week the first trotch
which is about a hundred thousand
hundred and ten thousand doses will come
into the pharmacy Distributors as soon
as it arrives it will be repackaged by
them and then distributed to pharmacies
around the province the next week we'll
get a bigger we hope to get a bigger
Toronto vaccine that will be used to
load up the health authorities make sure
they're ready for their start on the
19th and we will start issuing invites
as soon as we have vaccine in pharmacies
in the next few days hopefully
we will start issuing the highest
priority invites at that point in time
and you know allowing the commencement
of the campaign and it will be ramped up
and reach Peak by the third week in
September
now we do know that there are some
people who you know may not want to are
are not sure they want to do the
bivalent vaccine we Dr Henry's described
that it's a very good vaccine with added
protection against Omicron but we
continue to have mRNA the regular mRNA
vaccine the Pfizer and moderna available
we continue to have Janssen and novovax
available and we really encourage people
who perhaps are are not sure they don't
know enough about this vaccine get your
fall booster with either the existing
vaccines that you're very familiar with
or with novovax or jets and we we really
want people to be protected for the
respiratory season
National guidance is very very clear as
is Dr Henry's getting a booster dose
regardless of which vaccine is chosen is
the most important thing for you to do
this fall especially once you're six
months or more from your last dose
and finally for all the parents just one
more plug for those parents of children
you know who are anywhere from five to
eighteen get your get your kids
vaccinated and you know it's just it'll
be a real privilege for our team to
carry on providing this program to
support you know the fall booster to
protect our public keep our economy
going and make sure that those most
vulnerable are continue to be well
protected in this province thank you
very much over to you minister
thank you Dr Henry thank you Dr balam
and I just want to say finally before we
take your questions uh how important it
is to get vaccinated I think Dr Henry
and Dr ballum have made this clear
but we the priority we give to it you
can sense from Dr balham's briefing that
we're building up in a short period of
time to the capacity to vaccinate
between 250 000 and 280 000 people a
week that's an enormous effort by our
Pharmacy sector and thank you to
pharmacists by our doctors by our nurses
by other health professionals who are
taking part in these vaccination
programs it occurs at a time when there
are very significant demands on the
Health Care system and the fact that
this is such a priority for us and the
fact that so many people are
contributing to this effort demonstrates
its importance so there are lots of good
reason to get vaccinated to protect
yourself to predict the ones you love to
predict the ones you know don't know to
protect your community to protect the
Health Care System but there will be an
opportunity to get a fall booster I
encourage everybody everybody to get one
and I want to again thank all those in
British Columbia from people who work in
healthcare everyone in the province for
their ongoing support and effort as we
deal with the ongoing covid-19 pandemic
and with that we're happy to take your
questions
thank you as a reminder for reporters on
the phone please press star one to enter
the queue that's star one to ask a
question please also remember to take
your phone off mute you will not be
audible until your name is called for
media in the room please line up at the
microphone provided and someone will
check in with you please wait to be
called and make sure to provide your
full name and Outlet media will be
limited to one question and one
follow-up we'll be starting on the
phones today our first question is from
Richard zusman Global News please go
ahead
Dr Henry I'm trying to understand how
someone makes the decision around
getting the bivalent and the flu shot if
they want to do that at the same time
should people wait until that point in
October will the most vulnerable be
required or guided to wait until that
point if they need to get a flu shot how
does that decision get made and with
such a push for the bivalence are we not
going to waste a lot of the other
vaccine that we currently are providing
and currently have in stock
yeah so in terms of of you know who who
gets what when if you're somebody who
has not had a booster dose you should
get a booster dose any time now and get
your flu vaccine when it comes available
later on in October and we we kind of
titrate it so those people who are at
highest risk who most need the vivalent
booster are going to be at about five
five and a half months come October so
those are the people who had their
fourth dose in the spring vaccine
campaign so it actually you'd think we
planned it it actually lines up very
well for them to be able to get
co-administered their flu vaccine and
the covet booster so people in long-term
care people over the age of 70. so it
for them I we right now and I think this
is part of what we're challenged with
all of us is that we can't get rid of
certainty there's a lot of uncertainty
but this is our best guess on what's
going to happen and unfold over the
coming months so if you are younger you
only had two doses on board or it's been
a long time you're a health care worker
it's been longer than six months get
your your covid vaccine when it becomes
available in the coming weeks and you
can get your flu shot when it becomes
available later on in October so don't
worry so much about getting them
together we're trying to reserve that
for those people we know need both and
where we can get efficiencies by giving
it to people together
but I think we we do need to recognize
that if we start to see outbreaks and
long-term care for example or we start
to see surges in the community that we
will speed that up and we will change
our approach and make sure that we can
get booster doses regardless of whether
the vaccine the cover the influenza
vaccine is available or not so this is
our best guess right now and I'll as I
mentioned I'll be providing a little bit
more background about how we came to
those decisions uh next week when we
talk a bit about the modeling and and
thinking about what might unfold over
the fall in terms of vaccines that we
have on board now
um they are still the vaccines that we
need to give for dose 1 and dose two
because there are higher amount of
antigen in them and you need that to
start off with your primary series and
the primary series is still two doses we
have also learned that that third dose
is really important for for longer term
protection both from antibodies so
protection against infection but really
important for developing that robust
mature immunity against severe illness
that lasts a long time
I will also say
um that we that we have been titrating
how much we get from from the knock from
the uh National
um uh Supply
um so that we don't have a lot of excess
doses on hand and uh Dr balance team
have been working on that to make sure
that we're not wasting vaccine as much
as possible we do know that some of it
will be coming up and expiring in in
later in the fall and in the winter so
we we try and and as much as we can
titrate the types of vaccine for the
demand for those vaccines as as we have
been doing for the last year and a half
I will also say that this uncertainty is
something that and I've talked about
oscillations that are sort of getting
smaller and smaller over time and I do
believe we are going to be out of the
emergency response pandemic phase of
living with this new covid or SARS cov2
virus but we're not there yet so what
we're doing for this fall is based on
what we've learned that we're still in a
very uncertain period of time there's
still a lot of transmission globally we
still have the possibility of having new
variants that escape vaccine protection
potentially I think that's becoming less
and less likely as people globally are
vaccinated
but those are the things that we still
need to be prepared for over this coming
year I think that will emerge and then
we'll have a longer term strategy for
whether we need a booster every year or
whether we'll we'll get more information
about how long that protection lasts
especially the protection against more
severe illness and this time next year
I'll be talking in perhaps in a
different way
Richard did you have a follow-up
Dr Henry again considering that the
vaccination rate for 5 to 11 year olds
is so low and much lower than you know
the older age demographics what is the
province doing to change its approach to
encourage five to eleven year olds to
get vaccinated and will there be any
consideration being given to different
types of clinics including vaccinating
at schools a wider range of schools
across the province yeah that is a
concern for us I think there's been a
couple of things part of it is the
timing of availability of vaccine first
for school-aged children and there's a
lot of things going on this summer I
think a lot of people had experience of
infection and we've seen that in some of
the zero prevalence uh data that we have
that's we're just analyzing now and I'll
talk more about next week we've seen
that a lot of young people especially
school-aged children have had an
infection within the last six to eight
months so I think that impacts people's
decisions on whether to get a vaccine or
not so now we need to say yes even if
you've had an infection you need to get
that second that first or second or
third dose of vaccine and Now's the Time
to do it because it's going to give you
that stronger longer lasting protection
in that age group and we have been
working on a campaign to try and
increase awareness about those things
and you'll see some of that in the
coming weeks and yes uh in schools where
it makes sense so there are some schools
where that is will be a part of offering
school-based immunization but not all
schools because we know that local
public health knows where those
strategies work best and where people
are able to get vaccine and access
vaccine and we'll be able to titrate
that depending on the program
our next question
mail please go ahead
for taking my question given the lack of
uptake on the first booster shot are
expecting better uptake on the Bible uh
booster and what's your plan to ensure
that there's better uptake
Yeah we actually had pretty good update
for dose three but there is a as we talk
about 1.3 million people who have not
had that third booster shot and we have
been trying to understand what are
people's reasons a lot of it is because
um they were busy or they didn't feel
they needed it but a huge proportion of
people is because they had a recent
covet infection as well as we know
Omicron has been spreading quite a lot
so we we have heard from people that
about a third to to 40 percent of that
1.3 million people are willing to get a
vaccine they were waiting for the
bivalent vaccine so we will be targeting
and one of the things we're saying today
is if you're in that group of people
this is your vaccine to get in the
coming months
Joe did you have a follow-up
uh no I don't think
our next question is still on the phones
is for Moira White and the Thai please
go ahead
hi thank you for taking my question I
just want to clarify the fall booster is
being recommended for people no matter
how many
um initial shots they've had whether
that be the primary series or a third
booster first booster or a second
booster is that correct
a little bit of nuance is always with
these things I know it's complicated if
you've not had any vaccine you need to
get the original formulation with the
higher antigen dose but yes regardless
of whether you've had two or three or
four we're recommending for people who
are at highest risk and for all adults
that they get this uh this booster shot
after about six months
Moira did you have a follow-up
I do and they think about clarification
um following up on Richard's question
there is a really low number of small
children under or four and under getting
vaccinated how much of this do you
attribute to you know the newness of the
program and what strategies are you
going to be employing to kind of build
trust in in that vaccination program
yeah you know we I know there's a lot of
parents and I talked to many of them at
some of the clinics who are just really
relieved when we had a vaccine to
protect our youngest children you know
six months we know that infants are
particularly at risk and have can have
very severe illness with with covid
older children thankfully tend not to
get a severe illness but it's still
important to to protect them from
getting sick and we have seen a very
slow start to it where only about 10
percent of where we want to be and we've
heard a number of things from parents
about why uh they haven't yet brought
their younger children partly it's
because of timing when the vaccine
became available there was a lot of
people with lots going on during during
summer so we're hoping that that will
increase we've also been doing targeted
Outreach to to families with children to
remind them that they're we have these
clinics now the public health clinics
that are available for for kids and as
their younger children are getting up to
date and their other vaccinations will
be offered covet vaccine and as I
mentioned we're starting a new targeted
advertisement campaign to build some
confidence and to help parents answer
the questions that they have about
vaccination for our youngest children I
don't know if you want to add anything
to that yeah we you know it is a it's a
a decision
um that we heard many parents are
anxious to make for their children but
they have concerns about they want many
children parents want to wait a little
bit and see how it's working in other
children and we have more data now on an
ongoing basis about safety about how
well it's working about the vaccine
formulation itself for younger children
and how how effective it is so I would
encourage you to talk to talk to your
health care provider talk to your
pharmacist talk to your pediatrician
there's lots of great information for
parents on the bccdc website and also
through the vaccine evaluation center at
Children's Hospital about these specific
vaccines that are formulated for younger
children
yes yeah that's the other one of the
things that we've been uh working on is
is making especially the vaccine for
younger children available through a
pediatrician and family practitioner
offices because we know that those are
trusted sources for parents where they
feel comfortable bringing their younger
children to get immunized
our next question we're going to go to
reporter in the room please go ahead
hi uh Penny daffles from CTV News and
this is actually a question for Dr balam
could you just clarify does somebody
need an invitation to get the bivalent
vaccine
what happens if they show up and they're
not sure if they get the bivalent one if
you could just kind of clarify if
somebody makes an appointment for
example for next Tuesday thinking that
their Pharmacy is going to have the
bivalent vaccine should they expect that
that'll be the case or they only get it
if there's an invitation if you could
just explain that first so just to
clarify
um you you know we will not given the
size and the capacity we're trying to
create at this point it's By Invitation
Only and when you get your invitation
you you will we will assume that you
will want a bivalent vaccine if you're
eligible so if you're 18 and over that
would be the vaccine offered but if you
get to the clinic or the pharmacy and
you want to have the regular vaccine
that you've started with that's fine as
well
um if you if you don't want the bivalent
as I said and you would like to get your
fall booster with a novavax or or
potentially a Jensen you're 18 and over
um that that you have to do through the
call center but we are assuming that the
majority of people will want the
bivalent that will be sort of the
default vaccine but all of the regular
vaccines are also available on an
ongoing basis and as Dr Henry said if
you've never been vaccinated you need
that is that the regular vaccines we've
been using for the last two years are
the vaccines that would be used for that
primary series
uh second question for Dr Henry
um I know that you've been reluctant to
reintroduce Public Health measures but
you're also worried about the fragility
of the Health Care system and the fact
that we could be facing a double whammy
with influenza this year so I'm just
wondering
is it a metric of deaths due to covid is
it a matter of hospitalizations due to
covet plus flu what are the numbers that
you're looking at before you actually
consider reintroducing Public Health
measures to control potentially not just
covid but potentially also the flu as
well a really good question and there's
no one single thing and we talk about a
lot about what we're following what
we're looking at in terms of of what's
the transmission in the community
outbreaks who's getting sick who's
getting hospitalized
um the impact on health care workers and
the system so it is a little bit of
everything but I will also say that you
know the pool of people who are
susceptible is different now and and
that's because of the level of immunity
we have from infection and also
primarily from vaccination in the
combination so the the tools that we
used when we had no immunity and where
we needed to to take drastic measures to
slow down the spread of the virus or no
longer in some cases effective and are
no longer needed for the most part so
doing a mandate making it a legal
requirement for people across the board
to do something is actually a very it's
a last resort tool that we use very
judiciously in public health so I I
don't see us getting there unless we
have the emergence of something very new
and different where we have that
susceptibility again we know how to deal
with a lot of this we know that
ourselves all of us have had experience
with this virus now schools know how to
deal with it they've they've understood
the disruptions that some of the
temporary measures that we had in place
like cohorting and distancing and and
mandates Mass mandates the the impact
that they have on disruption of learning
in schools but we also know there's some
things that we need to keep doing all of
us so you know paying attention to
ventilation and indoor spaces paying
attention to cleaning paying attention
to our health awareness how am I feeling
today do I need to stay away from others
until I feel better
um and staying home with real hand
hygiene those are the things that we
can't ever lose and I hope we're baked
in but we can trust people now I think
in our community to do those measures we
don't need a heavy hand of putting in
legal restrictions in my opinion
our next question is also in the room
please go ahead
hi um my question will be for Minister
Dix on Frances thank you so much
um so I'll just need a couple of words
of francaise surface compound the
vaccination
um
a new event to your Donson pandemi he an
influence
on particularly not systems
person in opportunity
community
under
[Music]
the
amplus of Avalon campaign campaign key
checksumet
perfectionism is
did you have a thought
um
foreign
on also civilian come in because
preparation
[Music]
Japan
is
difficulty yeah
I'm particularly Clear Water
Mayo McKenzie a jetwind
service
is vaccine
foreign
we'll see a dunk on the uh
kind of Intel company vaccines you know
foreign
[Music]
that's all the questions we have for
today thank you yes thank you